bonjour à tous vous êtes bien nombreux
vous êtes venus de loin et ça fait bien
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu une si
belle réunion on est ici pour a célébré
la refondation d'une grande famille
d'une belle famille de notre famille
politique
cette refondation c'est votre oeuvre
c'est l'autre à vous qui allez voter à
plus de 96%
normalement ça doit s'afficher dans 96%
pour les statuts des statuts qui ont été
faits par vous et qui ont largement été
fait pour vous et je suis fier avec
toute la commission des statuts dont je
remercie chacun des membres et ils sont
ici présents d'avoir mené à bien cette
mission
nicolas sarkozy nous l'avait confié dans
la suite de sa campagne de l'automne
dernier c'était un engagement un
engagement pris devant vous les
militants vous avez tous participé d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors en votant
j'espère tous en répondant au
questionnaire en faisant savoir dans vos
fédérations
quelles étaient vos difficultés
d'aujourd'hui et vos souhaits pour
demain en tout cas cette oeuvre est la
vôtre
notre parti a souffert de la guerre des
clans désormais il ya un juge de paix
c'est vous les adhérents le vote
sera dorénavant la modalité habituel de
fonctionnement
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer
régulièrement sur les personnes sur les
idées choisir au suffrage direct
votre président de fédé ce sera en
janvier prochain
finis les petits arrangements pour
répartir les fonctions c'est vous qui
déciderez c'est vous qui trancherait
notre parti a souffert du sentiment que
les choses se décident est désormais
bien loin du terrain dans une certaine
opacité et bien maintenant la
transparence va être la règle des
militants présents dans toutes nos
instances dirigeantes ça a été dit tout
à l'heure ils sont les garants d'un
fonctionnement ouvert notre parti mais
chez un ami a souffert de défauts
d'exemplarité et c'est peu de le dire
ça nous ennuie dans le regard des
français
ça a été vécue comme une grande
injustice par nos militants qui donnent
de leur temps de leur énergie avec
tellement de générosité désormais
l'exemplarité sera la loi
aucun élu qui n'auraient pas à quitter
ses cotisations ne pourra siéger dans
nos instances locales et nationales et
je vois trésorier qui lève le pouce en
approbation
et je sais qu'il n'est pas le seul à le
penser parce que vraiment ça a été la
question qui a été plébiscité dans le
questionnaire plébiscité en nommant de
vote est plébiscitée au score notre
parti enfin il a souffert du manque de
renouvellement pas de jeunes élus dans
sa direction
si peu de femmes parmi ses dirigeants
désormais des places sont réservées à la
génération issue des dernières élections
dont on a vu d'importants représentants
tout à l'heure tous ces nouveaux élus
non parlementaire ils seront au bureau
politique et les membres élus au bureau
politique justement comme à la
commission nationale d'investitures
seront pour moitié des femmes
j'en vois qui sont d'accord où sont les
femmes
cette nouvelle direction vous l'avaient
plébiscité avec plus de 94% de vote
oui notre famille politique elle se
transforme elle est plus démocratique
elle est plus transparente elle est plus
moderne c'est votre oeuvre nous pouvons
être fiers du chemin parcouru ensemble
alors certes en voudrait que ça n'a
aucune importance mais qui peut
prétendre réformer la france
s'il ne s'est pas d'abord se réformer
soi-même en démontrant notre capacité à
nous moderniser nous nous donnons les
moyens de relever les défis et les
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres pour
relever la france c'est de rendre aux
formations à la plaine naturellement un
nouveau nom
comme pour une naissance au plus fort
encore comme pour une renaissance pour
écrire une nouvelle page de notre
histoire nous voulions un nouveau nom et
quel plus beau nom que celui des
républicains
les républicains mes chers amis c'est
notre histoire celle de partis
politiques qui ont souvent inscrit la
république au fronton de leur action lui
nr union pour une nouvelle république
lui dr union des démocrates pour la
république le rpr rassemblement pour la
république
j'en entends qui s'en souviennent les
républicains indépendants aussi l parti
républicain tout ça c'est notre histoire
des républicains
c'est notre identité certains ont voulu
nous la contester et vous ne savez pas
laisser faire vous n'êtes plus de 83% à
avoir plébiscité notre nouveau nom et
puis les républicains c'est notre projet
plus qu'une identité aujourd'hui c'est
un engagement pour demain mes chers amis
notre nom tourner le dos comme nous à
toutes les compromissions
il nous inscrire dans l'exigence la
république est belle elle est singulière
elle est généreuse elle est comme vous
les républicains donc c'est sous cette
nouvelle et large bannière que nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui la reconquête
des territoires comme le disait valéry à
l'instant après les départementales et
régionales
dans le chaos de la réforme territoriale
dont nous sommes nombreux ici à pouvoir
témoigner les identités locales se dilue
les français sont souvent perdus nous
serons nous les républicains une
référence une assurance un espoir c'est
sous sa nouvelle heure je bannière aussi
que nous devons proposer demain aux
français des réformes courageuses pour
notre pays
au fond la france bloquée souffre d'un
déficit démocratique il gangrène tout le
pouvoir
le monde associatif et syndical
l'administration qui trop souvent
gouverneur de contrôle et partis
politiques d'ancienne génération qui
sont peu à peu transformés en syndicat
d'élus république et démocratie sont
inséparables on voudrait nous faire
choisir sans démocratie tout ça sèche et
se dessèchent les sources se tarissent
les pouvoirs se sclérosent nous avons
désormais un outil pour faire vivre nos
idées nos valeurs
chacun y contribuera à sa manière
loyalement et en conscience
le parti mes chers amis il faut de la
cohérence et de la solidarité
mais ce n'est pas une caserne
c'est un espace de débats et d'actions
finalement en nous appelant les
républicains nous avons inscrit au
fronton notre parti les trois valeurs de
la république liberté égalité
fraternité c'est notre manière de dire à
nos du fond du coeur vive les
républicains vive la république et vive
la france